the right is losing
you can't find any empirical data that
the right is winning you ask about
abortion support for abortion being
legal in most situations is higher than
ever during the Roe v Wade era today
support for gay marriage higher than
ever you ask people do you think we've
done enough not enough or the right
amount when it comes to
um making trans people feel welcome in
society the majority says we have either
done the right amount or not enough
that's the and that's not the anti-woke
position I hate to break it to these
folks so that's why the right is trying
to steal elections rather than win them
they will likely ramp up their fascistic
rhetoric and it is in the data